do you know there's another reason why I
I left after the seventh season because
I signed on for the seventh season yeah
and I did that because people don't
understand that I actually signed on for
another yeah
but par part of that reason was two
other people left after season seven
yeah yeah it was you guys yeah yeah and
you I knew that was happening yeah and
you know I just felt like you know this
is kind of the end this is the time well
how many more stories it's what do you
do 160. I know and that's for us it was
like we've done it it's like yeah you
did it for the wrong reasons then you're
not doing it out of creative fulfillment
yeah and I agree respect for everyone
who went on and did it and and I'm not
dissing them all those show I haven't
watched it but for us as creative people
it's like there's a certain point you
run out of juice that you're like in
terms of doing one thing you know and we
went on and wanted to do other things
yeah this was the end of the road for us
yeah yeah we have no more stories really
to tell or that we were in and not if
not and we understood again and we're
glad that you know the network and the
studio wanted to keep making the show
and frankly we trained people who would
like they were chomping at the bit to
get into the driver's seat and let them
right it's a thing is television is a
team sport if you're on a long-running
show at a certain point it's you step
aside and let people that have new ideas
or yeah energy and enthusiasm come in
and keep take it's like a mirror
take the Baton and keep going so yeah
which is great it's almost like uh
sometimes you edit something and you're
just like yeah I just I just don't know
what else to do with this so you have to
give some young punk who's like you know
got the MTV mentality and he'll go and
he'll do something oh okay that's what I
need to say okay great do that that's
not what I do but no yeah and those
shows it's just it and again it's
something that nobody deals with anymore
because how many shows are 10 years but
you do need that refresh to keep it
interesting and so again we have no
regrets love the show like we did as
long as we did and we're certainly do
not regret leaving when we did and then
don't regret leaving when we did